Hi Chris. So much guys for
taking the time to be here. I'm,
I'm delighted to be here.
But more importantly,
I hopefully I will impact at least
one person here, IDD, all of you.
But I would like to impact one person
at least. So the, when you leave here,
you go out with a better mindset and a
better attitude towards life and also
towards your career. Does
that sound good? Wonderful.
So I'm just going to tell you a little
bit about me and then I got to tell you
where I was and how I
bridge the gap in between.
Because all of us want to
get somewhere in our lives,
whether that be in our personalized or
whether it be in business or a career,
but sometimes we just
don't know how to do that.
So I'm all about the how
because at one point in my life,
I didn't have the house
I just had. Oh, ish.
So I'm just going to show you a little
bit about my life at the moment.
And this is my little
boy. Um, I Christmas,
this is how we agree
while scared his presence.
And I just love doing anything to do
with adrenaline. But on the flip side,
I love doing art. Um, I love
media stuff. Anything really,
the kind of gives me a little bit of a
boss or a feeling of purpose for life. Um,
that's me. At one point
in my life, this was me,
so I was literally half
the weight I am now.
And so if you imagine if he split me
down in the middle and what you get,
I know the tied to belief, but that
was, uh, I know it's horrible. Um,
but this basically it was this a physical
representation of [inaudible] need and
a response to my environment.
That's all it was. Can
everybody see here? Yeah. Okay.
So that's what it was. And sometimes, you
know, I know this is physical graphics,
graphic representation, um, and
not all of us go in that route,
but our responses or behaviors
can be as destructive.
It could be anything from procrastination
to alcohol abuse, drug abuse, um,
being shy,
not putting yourself forward.
All those kinds of things are just
results of unmet needs and our reaction to
our environment. Because would you
agree? Have you ever met a negative baby?
No. Have you ever met, you know when
people say, Oh, I'm just a worrier.
Have you ever met a worry or a baby
or an anxious baby or a baby who is?
I'm just one of those pessimistic people,
never,
so we're born happy and successful. We're
just conditioned over time not to be,
and I'm going to show you proof of that
and how you can actually rise above that
conditioning and become the best versions
of yourself because that's what I
wanted. What I want here for you today is
to become a better version of yourself.
It's not up to me to decide what
it is you want in your life,
but I'm going to help you to get there.
This is what I want you to understand.
Life happens.
Every single person here has had an event
in their life that they haven't liked.
Some small events, some big events,
but you can't really compare a pain.
You can't really compare events as such,
but everybody has had some kind of thing
in life that has halted them to stop
them becoming the person that they're
really two are truly capable of the
calming and reaching your full potential.
And I'm going to tell you this
actually happened to me more than once.
And it's good to know that
because sometimes when you
become successful and by
successful,
I mean being the best you can be.
Sometimes when you become successful
you think you've made it and all of a
sudden you're flung back to the way
you were. So people often ask me,
why is it that I put my body like that?
It's not out of vanity.
That is not attractive,
which you all agree.
I put myself like that because when I was
seven I was raped and they didn't know
what to do with it. So I kept it in my
mind and that was the results of it. Okay,
you're going to flip from that image
because it's not very nice to look at. Um,
but that was the result of it.
I didn't know how my life just
went totally out of control.
So because I couldn't control it,
I came upon this thing called getting
the numbers down on the scale and that
happened to be at my felt in control of
my life. Control is a normal human need.
If it's torn off balance,
we do everything that we can to get
it met and we've lots of other needs.
And if we can't,
we go for the second best alternative.
And that's why we all go for second best
alternatives when our needs aren't met.
So eventually I did get better.
And the only reason I'm telling you my
story is not to impress you or to show
you where I am today is to impress upon
you that no matter where you are or what
you're doing, you can get what
you want with the right mindset,
the right skills in the right attitude,
skills and strategies that
can be learned for easily.
It's your attitude and your mindset
that actually predict her well.
You use those skills.
So when I got better and I
genuinely was better, I was healthy.
I was a leaving cert. I had a
boyfriend, I thought I had it made.
And relative leaving Cert,
I've gone out,
I was Mitch and skill to jumping
off the period you're in school.
And it was just, I really, really
was healthy and productive.
I got into first year in college,
it took a lot cause it was psychology
was very competitive, believe it or not.
And I thought I had it made.
Um,
and then in 1998 I had a car
accident and I hit my head, um,
during the [inaudible] I hit it here
on the side and my temporal lobe.
And about two weeks later I started
to experience kind of funny symptoms.
I was losing track of time. I
just wasn't myself. Um, you know,
and it was also hearing kind of mumbles
in my, in my mind. So I said to my mom,
I know there's nothing
psychologically wrong with me,
but there's something not right. She
said, yeah, I agree. So go to the doctor.
So I went to the doctor and the doctor
said to me, take antidepressants.
And I said,
suppose I'm not depressed.
And I genuinely wasn't cause I had
overcome all that stuff and but they said,
well take them.
Anyway,
the automatically jumped to the conclusion
that it was because of my earlier
years where I guess I was feeling low.
Um, so I talked the antidepressants.
Long story short,
I ended up in a psychiatric unit two
weeks later on 24 hour supervision,
which means if I walk over here,
I have the human shadow.
If I go to the bathroom, if I have a
shower, if somebody caught so many,
literally following me, they told
my parents that I had schizophrenia.
I to go on the medication,
highest office as quickly as possible
and to be committed on 24 hour
supervision. Both I and my parents,
new words in her schizophrenia.
But at the time my parents had used up
the insurance from my earlier years so
they couldn't use that.
You can't use the same insurance
on the same illnesses such, um,
so they didn't have the insurance
to cover my hospitals today. Um,
and are different to get a second opinion.
So I was there on in three months,
I was on 14 different medications.
You know when you see that person in like
say Phoenix Park or on Grafton Street,
Henry Street, and they're like this
and they're dribbling in the gut,
Crohn's under a tarp and stuff. I know
it's hard to believe that that was me.
So never judge a book by its cover.
I had,
my face was all puffy and I dribbled
with 14 different medications and
eventually my parents said, look, this
is, it's just not, not on, it's not right.
And they asked for a second opinion,
they pulled a few strings,
they're very good friends with a doctor.
They pulled a few strings and they got
me into another hospital and the doctor,
Pi, God, the doctor that I
was under, he says, look,
I'm going to talk to different
people are senior. And he did.
He asked my parents different questions,
um,
and he looked at my file and my dad said,
can you tell me this before the accident,
Donna was absolutely fine.
And after the accident, she's not
normal. It's the way he put it.
Can you not like accident shortly as
something to do with it. And they said,
what accident?
It wasn't in my file.
The scan that was taking of my brain
had shorter left him or left or my left
temporal lobe,
a Hematoma,
which is bruising of the brain
that also wasn't in my file.
So on paper it looked like
it's something very different.
So I spent another three
months in a psychiatric unit
because to take me off all
the other junk that I was put on.
So it got to a point in my life where the
first time when I had really difficult
times,
I was given a week to live.
So as that rock bottom and I had
to learn to build myself up again,
gratitude helped me to get that.
Believe it or not,
I started to have to think
about what is it that I do have,
not what I don't have.
But the second time round when I was in
the psychiatric hospital and the doctor
said, I have epilepsy, I said I
don't have epilepsy. And I was sick.
People telling me what I have and
I'm, I'm quite stubborn. I said,
I don't have epilepsy,
just give me proof that I have it.
So he sent down to the hospital
library and they bought,
brought up documents but this tick and I
sat in the bed and honestly I cried for
about an hour and it was just
tick, tick, tick, tick, tick.
All the symptoms that I was experiencing,
I had.
So the automatically jump to conclusion
that it was psychiatric when in actual
fact the head injury caused in your
logical disturbance in my body.
And I have epilepsy and I,
I still have epilepsy. Um,
so I had to build my life up from
where I was to where I am today.
Um, and thankfully I've learned
after different strategies,
I learned and worked with lots of
different people that you consider very
successful. I'm at 23. I
opened up my first company, um,
and in the first year of turned over
a million euro. Now you might think,
why am I even telling you that?
It's just to show you that,
that you can go from absolute disaster
to being happy and genuinely confidence.
And that's what I'm
going to show you today.
There's a difference between
being cocky and confidence.
If you want to be cocky or you want to
have the cello confidence just becoming
good actor, it's very easy to do. Um,
but if you wanted to have a genuine sense
of confidence where you don't have to
shout about it so much, you can just
be confident and feel good in yourself.
When you wake up in the morning
with a genuine smile on your face.
That's what I want you to have.
Would you like to have that? Okay,
so this is about, you got to decide.
You've got to look at your mind.
I'm going to show you how it works.
And then you've got to decide
whether you need to change your mind,
which is what I had to do.
And this is a question
you need to ask yourself.
Are you becoming a victim or a victor?
Everything happens to everybody in life,
different things.
But at the end of the day,
stuff happens to us.
It doesn't have to be majorly
traumatic or anything. Stuff happens.
But if you want to get to where you
wanted to get, you need to decide.
Are you going to become a victim
of your circumstance or a victor?
You may not know how to get
what it is that you want,
but the how was just a
strategy that can be learned.
You've got to make the decision
for us to become a victor,
so which are we going to be in the room?
Victories or victims?
Hands off. Anyone who would like to
be a victim. Look around the room
admittedly are some of you, you don't
have to put up your hands. Admittedly,
as some of you are looking or
feeling like a bit of a victim,
blaming the world for your problems.
If only they would do this,
then I could do this. If only I
were came from a better background,
I could achieve more. If only you had
better brains are more intelligence,
I would be better or whatever.
We're constantly doing comparisons because
we are a society of comparisons in my
opinion,
so it's so important that you literally
take ownership of your own life and your
own choices. No matter what background
you have, no matter where you came from,
who you know or watch your
current circumstances is
if you want to improve and
get to where you want to get to,
that's what you need to decide.
And if all decided here today that
you're going to be victorious.
So here's what you got to do.
You've got to decide and on your own life,
and I put business up there simply,
you can refer to your career or if you,
if you have a business or whatever,
you need to choose a new focus.
So when I was sitting on my bed and
I was crying and I thought, okay,
I've got to do something here,
I didn't want to get back to baseline.
I want to go more than that
because I thought, I'm not
going back to where I was,
but I knew how to get there from
the first set of events. Let's see.
But I guess it was harder the second time
because when you're knocked back once
and twice and you're kind of think,
well,
maybe it'll happen again or something will
happen again. It's a natural question.
And,
but I had to decide that's liberty.
I had to get stopped with myself and I
have to say quit the crap and really just
own your own life and become responsible
for your own life and become greater
than your problems.
This is what y'all want you to understand.
You are not your problem. If you
make your story, your identity,
you will never do anything
worthwhile in your life. Effort,
not to the full extent that you can really
achieve what it is that you want to.
So decide what you do want. Most people
look at what they don't want. Well,
I don't want to be sad anymore or
I don't want to be shy anymore.
Don't want to be anxious anymore. I
don't want to be this, that or the other.
If you want to get what
it is that you want,
you've got to decide with clarity what
it is that you want. You're all Googlers.
If you decide you want to
search something in Google,
do you put in something that you don't
want? That's kind of Dolton, isn't it?
So you've got to put in
exactly what you want.
So you've got to tell yourself what you
want. Put yourself in a strong state.
Look at the resources around you.
You have so many resources.
What can you use no matter how small
to get you to where you want to get to.
I create a why I put
that back there as well.
If you've got to Hawaii to do something,
you will do anything.
How many people here admittedly get in
better shape when they have a holiday or
a wedding coming up? They go, well I'm
not going to sit in the back on the beach.
Look and like you know,
everybody else is there out there with
their beach buddies and it gives you a
motivation to do it.
Admittedly are a wee bit like that.
And if we want to give up cigarettes,
we have to put up a why behind it.
So when you get to Hawaii,
when you get a bit of an engine
behind what it is that you want to do,
you'll be able to do it a lot easier.
So look at what it is that you want to do.
If it can identify it. If not just play
around with what you might like to do.
I put a why behind it, so I had to
get a Hawaii behind getting better.
My why was, I was sick of seeing my
parents cry honestly, and then I thought,
I'm going to be stubborn. I'm going
to get what it is that I want to get,
but I've got to get my white and that
was my initial way to get an initial why
and then build it up.
This is what you've got to decide to.
Are you going to be
interested or committed?
How many people here turned
on the computer this morning?
Where your you interested in doing
this or were you committed to doing it?
Try and put your hand up.
Please
try and put your hat time.
Put your right hand up then.
Okay. Just try and put your
right hand off. I'm not,
I'm not asking you what your interests
are committed. Just put your time.
Put your right hand off.
Okay.
I said try. I didn't say put it up. Okay.
Most people will put it up. Try and
doing are two totally different things.
If you want to get a result,
you've got to commit to it.
You don't have to be interested.
I think it into my car and got one
so interested in driving. Yeah,
maybe I'll do it.
Maybe I won't.
Or I say put the key in and just put
my foot on the accelerator. Then you,
then you get somewhere,
so you have to become not interested.
You need to become committed to what
you're doing. Remember these three ps?
I don't know how well they're highlighted
here. Plan, prepare and proceed.
Google maps. If you want to
get somewhere, you need to,
first of all, you need to type it in.
You need to decide if to size for you,
which is the best route to get
there. That's smart, isn't it?
If you don't decide where you want to go,
you'll end up either.
Nowhere are so many you don't want to be,
so identify the best route to get there.
Look at the skills and
the support that you need.
Now imagine like driving a car.
If I'm driving a car,
I've got certain boundaries in the car,
I need to make sure that I've got things
with me in case I break down or I've
got some resources or I've got some kind
of maybe telephone numbers that I can
ring in case I break down or a case I
hit it hit an obstacle. That's smart,
isn't it?
Most people don't put those in the lives.
Most people do not prepare for. If
something happens, what will I do?
So for example,
let's say I meet an event in my life,
which is very likely where my life goes
totally out of control for whatever
reason or perceive it to be that way.
Do you think I could go back
to the way I was? Absolutely.
I could. Do you think I will? No Way.
And the reason I won't is because
first of all, I've chosen not to.
I've committed not to,
but most importantly I've strategies
in place that if I feel like that way,
if I feel vulnerable,
I know exactly what to do to
prevent me from going back there.
So this is why you've
got to have strategies.
And skills in place to get you to
where you want to go. Focus forward.
If you're driving a car, do most of your
drive here, okay? If you don't drive,
you been in the car with
somebody who does drive.
If they drove looking in their rear view
mirror, what would you think of them?
Let's drive. What would
you think? They're insane,
right?
So you'd want them to focus forward.
Most people in the lies focused backwards.
They're constantly looking in the rear
view mirror where I do, I want to do this,
but this happened before I
wanted to do this, but you know,
it didn't work out the last
time or whatever. Focus
forward on what you do want.
If you meet obstacles along the
way, so [inaudible], that's life.
You just learn how to overcome them.
If you need help to overcome them,
you get that head to overcome them.
But everyone has those obstacles.
But as long as you're focusing
forward in the right direction,
you have a good chance of getting to
where you want to go. I have done here,
choose your team. Most people in
their lives do not choose their team.
Imagine if you're in a car and you've
got a bunch of people and one is shouting
at you from the back.
One is firing papers at you.
One is putting the hands of your eyes.
What would you say to them?
Stop or get out of the car.
So imagine that your life is like a car.
You either have to tell people to stop
or remove them. It don't mean kill them.
I mean just not delete
them. Just a disclaimer,
but just maybe to step aside from them
or limit your time with them if people
aren't in line with or matching
what it is that you want to do. Now,
here's the thing.
Everybody has a family.
So some of us have bigger families than
others and I have what you might call
liquids, Arthur or
thoughts, all sorts. Um,
they're not all pro my goals. Some
of them think they're mass. Um,
some of them are very straight forward.
Some of them are very eh straight.
Some of them are very
hippie like or whatever.
But I've got to choose who I
need to have in my life. Family,
you can't really get rid off such as,
limit your time with the ones
that you don't enjoy with towards.
He blame me. Um, but choose
who you want to be around.
But that's not a snobbery thing at
the end of the day, and it, there's a,
there's a phrase which I
think is a wonderful phrase.
If you're in a plane and the
pressure drops, what do you do?
Put on your own air mask first.
If you're not looking after yourself,
you can't look after other people.
Everyone has their own individuals lives
to lead and they are responsible for
their own lives.
So stop being responsible for their lives.
Be responsible for your own on your own
life and make sure that who you surround
yourself with are people who actually
are going to help you get to where you
want to get to. Find an expert.
This is something that I had to do.
I had to find experts because they didn't
want to kind of do it the slow route.
Again, I wanted to get to where I
wanted to get to, but I didn't know how,
as I said,
so I had to find people who had what
I wanted regardless of circumstance.
So I thought,
what if I could find people that had
been through Robert Circumstances but had
become successful despite them and I
figured if I modeled their results or if I
model their strategies,
I should come up with similar results.
That's the be correct.
If I want to be a good chef,
would I find a mediocre chef or what I
find the best if I want to become really
good at it, you find the best.
So if you want to do something,
you've got to find the best at
it and model their strategies.
So learn from experts.
When I learned to drive,
I made sure I learned from
somebody who knew how to drive.
It wouldn't be very smart order to learn
to drive from somebody who hadn't a
clue what they were doing.
No,
but most people learn from people who
haven't a clue what they're doing.
Believe it or not.
In my industry.
There are a lot of people teaching or
explaining and they actually don't have
the results that they're talking about.
You will be shocked.
There are so many experts teaching
stuff and they don't have the results,
so for me,
it's more important to find somebody.
I don't care what education somebody has,
I don't care where they're from,
who they know. As long as they've
got the results that I can follow.
That's what I'm interested in
and everyone knows one of those.
You may not know them personally if you
don't find them and model exactly what
they do. You do not need to have
all the answers. Nobody does.
Even if they say, everybody says,
Oh, I know it all in their minds, no,
you don't throw any Noel's here.
Everyone's going, yeah, he is. Yeah,
she is, but the fact is nobody knows
everything. I'm still learning.
Everybody is still learning
and practice your actions.
There is no point
thinking about something.
You've got to do this and you got
to practice it and practice it.
Remember when you first got your
computer and you learn to use this,
are you better now than you were
at the beginning? Of course,
some people don't know.
Think of that image council workers.
I hope nobody here is a council worker
Prac time, but in the event that you are,
there's no point staring into a whole,
staring into a mess and looking at it
and have when all your other people that
you don't want in your life join,
you were looking at and say, Oh God,
that's such a mess. That's
such a mass. Or what do we do?
Let's all join in and talk about it.
Let's talk about people
who were also there before.
You know that doesn't get you anywhere.
Your brain is their most valuable asset.
People learn strategies all
of the time sort of way,
but unless you have your brain behind it,
your engine behind it,
it is like turning on a
computer with no power.
You don't get results. You have
to have your mindset, right first.
Mindset equals money set
mindset equals blank set.
Everything you do is based on your
mindset. Do you perform better?
If you're feeling better,
if you've had a really,
really crappy evening and you're coming
to work and you just don't want to talk
to anybody, nobody does that
today. Everyone has those days.
So you've got to put power
behind what it is that you want.
And I'm going to show you this
using an analogy of a computer.
You can all relate to this right now,
if I pick up my phone
and I have here on my phone,
I said I actually called my phone
because my son likes to get us.
If you look at all of those apps
on my phone, how do they get there?
So more put on when I got it right.
And so my put on,
so maps actually arrive on my phone.
I've absolutely no idea
where they came from.
Ads for products that I have no interest
in that just pop up on my phone.
I don't know how they got there,
but there's something been
downloaded all the time.
You're probably responsible for.
So actually that has just gone.
It was here. Look in your face. They gave
it away. So I want you to imagine this.
Imagine somebody as a total novice,
they don't know anything about computers,
which you are one time.
And we go into a computer store
and we ask the computer person,
they person in the store,
look, can you help me? They're
the expert. And they said,
no problem. And they feel wonderful about
themselves. They come over and you said,
well will you pick out the best computer
for me please? So they go in there,
pick out the best computer that they think
is the best one. So this is wonderful.
And you say, well, I don't
know how to use emails,
but I hear everyone else's using them.
So can you just put that on too?
And Microsoft word or whoops Google,
but for,
for chrome and private, whatever you
want on it, I don't know how to use it.
So will you do it?
So they're saying no problem at all.
So they put all their stuff on and
then this happens. We get home,
we become frustrated. It's not
working. Things start to crash.
Email staff to arrive for everything
you could possibly imagine.
I have gotten emails from
people that I don't know.
I have won the lottery so many times.
There are people in Algeria who
wants to give me a million euro.
I don't know who they are,
but they arrive all the time.
And if I don't know anything
about computers, what'd you think?
I'd open those junk math.
Of course you would at the beginning.
Now you may not know because he know
better, but at the beginning you're open,
everything don't Ya. And program
staff to crash. And we think,
is this something wrong with us?
So imagine when you first use a computer
and just stuff wasn't working or if for
now if a program, is it working for you,
it kind of, it's frustrating isn't it?
And sometimes you kind of thing,
what? What is wrong with me?
Why can't it just get this?
Right? So using that analogy,
and I like to use analogies
because it simplifies things.
I want you to imagine the computer,
like your brain when you were born,
when you're born, we have a basic
computer with a basic brain.
We have the ability to learn the language,
the ability to move and the
ability to feed. That's kind of it.
How do you think you have
the accent that you have?
You learned it and you
constantly exposed to it.
Some of you here have been exposed to
second language rather than your first
language because you're around it.
The more you're around it,
the better you get at it.
And all information comes into us
like apps on a phone or a computer.
It comes in constantly. Our accent,
our walks, I got the raw deal.
I got a mail accent,
like seriously flat,
as a whatever.
Um,
but everybody has an accent simply
because it came in to your brain.
Every opinion you have,
every cultural opinion you have,
every religious opinion you have,
everything that you have in your brain
was downloaded either by your environment
or by somebody else. You just let it in.
Same way the stuff gets into my phone,
somebody put it in there. Sometimes
I download stuff that isn't good,
but of course in there, and that's
the exact same as our brains. Now,
this red thing here represents emotions.
Sometimes our brain has emotional tanks,
but what that means is you're here.
There's lots of information going on,
the lights of the fan,
the camera, everything.
You couldn't possibly focus on it all at
the same time, you will go crazy, right?
So we filter information,
we narrow it down to the things
that are important to us.
The things that you could focus
on that you need to focus on.
And sometimes there's emotions tanked
to information. It's like a guest,
an app or a CD if you imagined
or or a DVD, whatever.
You just put it into your brain.
So if you imagine you go
through life for example,
and you get into school before you go to
school, you think you're really smart.
Like my four year old at the minute,
he is a genius as far as he's concerned.
He actually did a picture yesterday,
I have to say, he's very creative.
So I did call him a genius on Facebook.
He is wonderful and I give praise.
I'm totally bias.
Now what happens when he goes into school,
do you think is going to start
getting color inside the lines?
Make sure you do this correctly. If you
get an a, you're a god. If you get an F,
you're a real rubbish.
He gets all different information.
Hopefully I'll be able to prevent
or at least reframe some of that.
But he got all that stuff. So we
actually monitor and I guess equate what,
how we are and how valuable we are in our,
your identity to our performance in
society and what society tells us as good.
So let's imagine I'm in school and my
teacher tells me that I'm stupid or I get
an f or I get it a g or you get whatever.
And automatically my brain tells
me that means I'm not good enough.
So I download it and it's emotionally
tact. Now here's the thing.
All of our senses are involved in
this. Our feelings, what we see,
everything. So of course in like
almost like just like a, um, a movie.
It goes into our minds and a place,
if there's a lot of emotion tag to it,
it would play a lot.
If there's not really much emotion,
you're probably don't even notice it.
Our brains purpose is to keep us alive
and safe. It likes to keep us comfortable.
So if it recognizes something in the
environment that it doesn't like it,
we'll try to avoid it or try and deal
with it. It's called fight or flight.
So if we have an emotional tank,
two piece of information or to something
that happens in our lives that makes us
feel uncomfortable, if we come across
that again or something similar,
your brain has to generalize.
How did you know to sit on that chair?
Because we've sat in a chair before
and you know what a chair does.
How do you know when you walk into a
door that opens this way or that way?
The first time you walked into
a door or not into the door?
Through the door and the
first time that you did that,
maybe when you were a baby you had to
kind of figure out what does this do.
But our brain generalizes generalized as
positive and negative. So for example,
when that happened to me when I was
younger, it was a one off event.
There was lots of emotions
obviously tagged to it,
but my brain in order to keep me safe
and comfortable, said from now on,
if I experienced anything like this again,
trigger all those same emotions and then
I have a chance to decide what to do
with them. So can you imagine if I went
into a situation and I got bullied,
which is kind of control
taken away from you as well,
how do you think they'd react?
Yeah,
no. If you imagine if somebody started to
ask me where you're going and what time
will you be back, do you think
that might have bothered me then?
Yeah, because I felt they were
controlling me. There probably weren't,
but I felt that they were so it
generalizes. It's like a Hoover,
it sucks everything off.
And then says from now on,
anything I see or hear or
smell or taste or feel,
I'm going to trigger those same emotions.
And that is why if somebody,
for example,
is afraid to give a presentation,
it's probably because at some point
in your life you would have seen or
experienced judgment at a presentation
and you didn't like it or you saw
somebody that maybe people
laughed at or something like that.
If you're afraid to do something,
it's because somewhere in your mind
you've got a CD playing or a movie playing
the Tattoo. If I did this, this
is what happens. We all got those.
Everybody does.
That happens in the limbic system.
The limbic system is basically a really
primitive part of the brain. It's habit.
It is very, I'm not saying
that came from x by the way.
I'm just saying that it's as primitive.
It's as dumb as an ape.
It's very black and white. It doesn't
see the difference. Reasoning or nothing.
Reasoning is part in a
different part of our brain,
so it's all to do with emotions,
to do with memories,
to do at responses to do
reward and desire. La Memories.
Everything is all banked in the
limbic system and what it does.
This is how it works,
and this is really important
that you pay attention to this.
It can't tell the difference between
what's real or imagined at a neurological
level. Admittedly, I'm
guys can admit this too.
If you're in a movie or watching a DVD
and it's a horror movie and all of a
sudden something starts to happen and
your heart starts to beat and your sweat
glands start to activate and your blood
pressure goes up and you're like, Oh God,
I don't want to see this.
Even though you know it's green screens,
all special effects and they're acting.
So why would your body physically respond
because of the New York neurological
level?
The limbic system cannot
tell the difference between
what is real or imagined.
So it responds anyway. And the more our
body physically response to something,
the more adrenaline and
cortisol is released, the
more we shy away from things.
If the emotion is negative.
Also,
it does not filter information.
Now, do not, and I'm telling you,
do not think of a pink elephant.
I said,
don't now.
Whatever you do,
I don't want you to think of Grafton
Street and you're going up and wow,
there's a red dress in the shop window
and then all of a sudden you see a yellow
football on the ground. Don't think of
that. You've all thought of it, right?
So our brain doesn't differentiate.
It's like a junk mail. It just,
everything just comes in.
It's up to us what we engage in,
but everything comes in.
So everything somebody says to you,
your register almost like as a download,
it's off to you what to do with it.
But if you've got these programs going
on in your head that's emotional or
emotionally tagged, it kind of makes
a deal with it ineffectively as I did.
Here's the other thing. It was responsible
as it said, for the fight or flight.
Do I deal with it or do I run away
programs?
Our behaviors and habits and it's
strengths strengthens a responses to
repetition. If I have a dumb bell here and
I do that, it strengthens my arm. Right?
But I won't really know what a sec,
cause there's only done once.
What if I keep doing it?
What happens?
You're all judging my arm right now.
No, I do not go to the gym too much,
but it's suppose to get stronger.
You all speak the language,
you speak because we've practiced it.
You all can do this because you've
practiced it. The more you do it,
the better you get at it. And this
includes our thinking and our mindset.
The more we talk to ourselves.
Admittedly,
have you ever felt a bit of a sniffer,
like a cold and you didn't really want
to go into work or he didn't want to do
something and it's all God, I fed off the
cold. I can feel my sinuses blocking up.
Yeah, I think my throat is going as well
and they start coughing and you start
actually talking yourself into it.
We do it all the time.
We don't even realize that part of the
brain is like an engine in the background.
We don't realize what is happening.
So this is about becoming
conscious of what you're doing.
Become very aware of what you're
doing and things can change.
Change perspective. Now
I'm going to normally,
I don't wear sunglasses, so I thought
I put them there just in case.
When you signed up for a minute please.
Oh No.
If you were four, do you think you'd
have, you'd mind standing up? No.
Okay. Put those on. Turned around. She
looks lovely. It doesn't shake. Okay.
Now just turn around there for a second.
The room is the way it is right now.
How does it look now?
A lot darker now.
Can you imagine if she walked
around with the sunglasses,
what she would look at and what you
would see us take them off now? Okay.
It's the fact that
what we see in the world is predicted by
what filter we have. If I walk around,
for example, with this phone in
front of my eyes, all my downloads,
that's how I'm going to see the world.
So it's not necessarily the
people think of you a certain way.
If you have programs
learning in your mind,
you think that they do you perceive
that they do cultural differences,
race differences, um, everything
from, you know, the way people look,
the way people dress,
the way people speak.
We all perceive that they're going to be
a certain way because of our downloads,
because of the information
we grow up with. We perceive
various different things.
So do you think that I could perceive
the people were controlling my life after
that event happened? Absolutely.
Where are they controlling my life?
No.
When somebody said to me when I was at
my lowest weight and someone said to me,
Donnie and I was getting back up
and you're starting to look better,
I hated them.
I absolutely hated them.
Yet to look a little bit better would
have probably be healthier. Right?
So it didn't make any sense that
I would want to look better.
So I used to think everybody was
telling me if they said I look better,
it meant there were telling me I was fat,
which was just a perception.
That's odd. So everything that you do
in your life is a perception of reality.
It's not necessarily reality.
Does that make sense?
So you've got to change the
perceptions that you have and be all.
Put your mind to new thinking,
open your mind to different opinions.
Open your mind to different
ways of looking at what
you want to achieve and how
you might achieve it.
Understand the perspective
is not the same as reality.
And this is a question you need to
ask is are you prepared to allow your
perceptions or your programs to
determine what you do in your life?
If somebody calls you stupid,
are you prepared to allow them
to control what you achieve?
If you grew up in a
really disadvantaged area,
are you going to allow that to
dictate how wealthy you become?
If you decided that you want a promotion
but you don't think you can because
your sister told you that you probably
won't get it, are you going to dictate?
Allow that to dictate what you do?
That's your decision that you have to
own your life and allow yourself to make
decisions based on your new reality.
If that makes sense?
And this is neurological, guys,
this is not me just talking theory.
This happens for real.
You are literally being wired
every single minute of your day.
As I've been talking,
you've been thinking different ways.
You've been reframing stuff. You've been
thinking, well, how does that apply to me?
Or how could I use that in the future?
How could I use it? This circumstance,
right? So when you're doing that,
you're changing your perception,
and all that takes is bringing experts
into your life that have good ones.
Literally choosing the downloads
that you get in your brain,
choosing who you talk to. If you talk
to miserable people all day, guess what?
You're going to feel miserable if you
are watching it. Here's the fix, right?
You go home from work,
Yay eastenders half an hour
coronation street after it.
I think a fair city at some point.
Then you watch maybe the news or you
might hear the news every hour. Remember,
your body is physically responding.
So if you are watching somebody scraped
and somebody else's eyes out on the
pavement,
over rival over,
someone who's had an affair or
you're watching the news every hour,
your body is physically responding
and wiring you. Neurologically.
My body was wired neurologically
for unproductive responses.
So if you want something in
your life or your career,
whatever it is that's up to you, you
have to wire yourself correctly for it.
The only things you should be putting
in your mind as positive information,
productive information, everything you
read, who you talked to, what you watch,
and it does have a difference. I
am. I am living proof that had have,
it has a difference.
I used to talk myself miserable.
I used to say everything to myself that
I could possibly say that was negative.
But once I started to seek out experts
or people who knew what they were doing,
successful people successful basically
to me has been the best you can be in
whatever area you choose.
So what if I was to find those
people and let them download on me?
If them tell me what it is
that I need to be worried for.
Do you think that would be a smarter move?
Okay,
so think about who it
is that you can learn.
You may not personally know them, read
about them. Some of you have my book.
Read it. Do with does exercise
in it. Look at people on TV.
How do they walk?
How do they talk if they feel confident?
If I walk along like this, do you think
my neurology or make me feel confident?
Absolutely not.
Cause here's the thing,
your body and your mood I
directly related. It's called
a psycho cybernetic loop.
You're literally,
if I look down like that,
my body will tell me that pasture matches
feeling that if I Kerlin like that,
if I want to do something really well,
what if I gave a presentation like that?
How to think I give it? Or if I sat down
like this and I walked over like this,
how do you think I give that presentation?
Not Strong. So if you want to,
for example,
do you want to engage with new people or
you want a new relationship or you want
to learn something new,
make herself in that pasture.
Think of if I knew someone who was really
good at this and you may just know of
them, how would they stand? What
tone of voice would they have?
How would they breathe?
At one point in my life,
I was literally afraid to
cross the road on my own.
I had to get my mother to hold my hand.
Before that,
I didn't want to go outside my door.
I used to go into my bed as my mother
called her. I used to go into my whole
and for me I had to do it gently,
so I had to go in for a cup of coffee,
which was terrifying.
I would genuinely have preferred
to chew on glass and do that.
How am I up here talking to you?
I have to decide.
I had to become committed.
I had to get the skills and practice them
often till become wired for it so that
it becomes as natural to me as breathing
and every single thing
that you want to do.
You can do it just by
wiring yourself force,
so assess your current life, assess the
downloads you're putting into your brain.
If you're literally working on your
laptop and you're looking at things,
you typing in stuff that's
negative all the time,
or you're typing in crappy calls.
If you're trying to learn something,
how do you think you're going to fail?
So why do it for real?
Because we have become conditioned to
do it naturally in Ireland especially,
and I'm sure it is across the world,
it's almost bad to become successful.
The minutes almost becomes bankrupt.
Yes,
they've lost all their property.
I'm so delighted because they were
greedy anyway, all of this stuff,
we celebrate people when they fail because
it makes us feel more comfortable now
in saying that I don't anymore.
I love it when people are successful,
when people are happy and achieve their
goals because they think differently.
I look at people differently. I
almost, it's like if somebody,
imagine people are ringing you and I say,
do I want to answer them or not?
Imagine if they're going to fill my mind
with been talking about somebody else
hasn't been really mean.
Well, I answered no.
So why answer Fifo or answer masters or
answer information from the environment?
It's if it doesn't make you feel good,
only an answer and engaged and open
up information that makes you feel
wonderful, find it, read it,
put it into your brain,
download it and practice it.
You can do this as a little tip. This is
something that I do. It's very simple,
but it's quite effective. I want you to
imagine a delete button in your head.
Okay?
There it is.
If somebody say something negative to you,
and that includes yourself.
If you watch the news more than
every half an hour or every hour,
I want you to press delete,
literally imagined pressing it.
Can you all imagine that
button in your brain?
If you can't imagine it visually look at
this and feel it going into your brain
or hear that sound
okay, so deleted. Importantly,
you need to replace it with something
positive. So if for example,
I say to myself, I can't afford
it and it makes me feel bad,
how about reframing it and saying,
how can I afford it?
What do I need to do to afford it?
It's a different question and
you'll get a better answer.
The questions you answered determine the
answers. Sorry. The questions you ask,
determine the answers that you'll get.
If you ask crappy questions,
you're going to get bad answers.
If you ask better questions or
reframe questions, guess what?
You're going to get better
answers and better solutions.
Imagine this,
hear it.
I want you to imagine
going into your brain.
I also want you to do something else.
Who's right handed here?
Okay. This evening or today, if you
have them here, I'm sure you do.
Get an elastic band and put it on your
left hand. Who's on your left wrist?
Who's lefthanded?
Okay.
Get an elastic bands and put it on
your right hand. Now, here's the thing.
I want you to wear this for 24
hours. If anybody asks, say,
that Lunatic Donna
Kennedy made me wear it.
There is a reason and people may
ask why you over elastic bands.
Anytime you think something negative
about yourself or somebody else,
I want you to get it depending on your
hand and I want you to do this and then a
spring back so it hurts,
right?
It will shock you were in the shower
everywhere for the next 24 hours.
It will shock you how many, many negative
thoughts you engage in every day.
It is like sitting at your computer and
opening up negative emails all of the
time. I'm wondering why you
don't feel good to perform. Well,
look at what it is that you're opening up.
What is it that you want to hear
in your life so every single time,
no matter when it is or where it is
buying a Gordon had whack it off your arm.
I go, I shouldn't have done that.
No. Why am I asking you to do that?
Not to give you pain it,
although it will hurt.
I'm only asking you to that because
here's the thing, it's physical.
Your body will go, oh, I didn't
expect that. So changes the pattern.
When I'm asking you to put a positive
program in there or delete your negative
programs and put a positive one in its
place, your brain doesn't expect it.
Our brain is conditioned. So Chester's
that how many people? Honestly,
if we left this room and came back,
he'd sit in the same seat.
Okay,
no. Imagine if somebody has sat
in your seat, would you go, well,
she didn't sit in my seat. Move.
Because we get into habits so easy.
How many people have their side of the
couch that they sit on or their mug or
you go and when you go home you put your
keys in the same place all the time.
What I would even thinking or you drive
home and you don't realize how you even
got there.
You could be thinking of something else
because we do things on automatic and I
want you to learn stuff on automatic that
will help you to be the best that you
can be.
That's going to help you doing this will
actually help you because it'll throw
your brain off track.
It doesn't matter what you do.
Where do you slap yourself in the face?
Whether you drink a drink you don't like?
What do you smell? Something you don't
like as long as it interrupts your brain.
But I want you to just do that because
it's really simple and if you ever do it
again in the future, put that elastic
band back on and watch what happens.
You will genuinely be shocked out how
much negative rubbish you're putting into
your lives. So hands up. Who
is going to become a victor
now to physically get it? I want
you to stand up and become a victor.
Oh my God, I'm standing up.
People are looking at me. No,
this time look slightly above eye level,
just slightly provider level.
I saw you walking like I have this gut.
Breathe deeply.
Now think of someone who's super
confident and relaxed in a way,
but they've got genuine confidence. You
might see them on TV or might know them.
Now think like them. How would
they walk? How would they breathe?
Would you walk differently?
Okay,
now I want you to all for a second,
look down at the floor.
Put your shoulders in like this.
How do you feel? Okay, now look back
up. Look slightly provide level,
and she breeds already.
So sit down.
If you engage your brain correctly,
you will embrace the day differently.
You'll start to behave differently,
but you need to do after.
This is not a onetime thing.
You need to continually do it
until it becomes automatic.
And I'm going to finish up on
this because I know time wise,
get out of your own way.
The only person stopping you from doing
what it is that you want to do is you.
If you decide and commit they,
you're not gonna take any rubbish anymore
that you're not going to settle for
second best that you want to actually
live the life that you want to live.
Why not to us what stuffing and every
single person who has achieved anything
great has overcome adversity.
Most people who are world renowned,
great thinkers,
great achievers,
Einstein failed maths.
Walt Disney was fired from his job.
Guess why?
For lack of creativity.
Michael Jordan was thrown
off his basketball team.
All of these people failed, but here's
how I want you to think of it. Fit.
There is no such thing as failure. It's
feedback. If something doesn't work out,
go, what can I do differently?
How can I do it differently?
Ask better questions and importantly,
take action.
If you just wish for something, it's
just a dream, but if you take action,
it becomes reality and
that is the gap in between.
I used to wish for a better life.
Sometimes I prefer to
trade my life for nothing,
just to do away with it.
That was then.
Now I make better questions.
I ask better questions,
I make better decisions and I focus
on better things and importantly,
I take action on those. I don't wish
anymore. If I want to do something,
I don't have to know how to do it.
I've just got to do it and find
someone who's done it before me.
Do you all know someone who's done
something successful before you?
Everybody has.
Everybody knows somebody like that.
Find the strategies and model
them and keep taking action.
And keep doing it and keep doing
it and keep them do it or tell you,
get the result that you want and you
will get the results that you want and
remember the phrase,
we are all born happy and successful.
You're conditioned not to be.
Now that you know that,
I want you to be your best
version of yourselves,
I reach your potential and I'd
like to thank you on that note
[inaudible]
and thank you so much.
We're going to,
I'm going to maybe one or two questions
and I'm going to have three minutes left
and then we'll go to audience questions
very quickly and please wait until
either myself or John get
a microphone to you. Some
other to start with is that after
each of the major events that you've
experienced and you were coming
back and can really strong again,
there must've been lots of times when you,
you kind of want,
you wanted to give off.
What strategies did you use or
or just why didn't you actually,
why didn't you give up?
I didn't give up because I knew
that there was something better.
I didn't know how to do with what.
I knew that there was something better
and I was sick of seeing my parents upset.
I watched other people have what I wanted
and I guess I just knew there was a
slight glimmer there that I might be
able to do it if I could get the right,
the right people behind me in the
right resources. And I guess I,
I on to that hope because when you've got
a bit of hope, if you can do anything.
So that's why I grasped that hope.
And I also became grant became very
grateful for everything that I have,
not what I don't have any,
you've had lots of brilliant achievement.
What in your mind,
in your gracious achievements?
Having my baby
and general wife,
that was bloody painful.
It was the most painful thing ever.
But sometimes it takes bit of pains.
They get great results and uh, yeah,
that was my greatest achievements.
I on all the other stuff, but that
was a great, my greatest achievement.
That's fantastic.
This is the points, and I said
this to, to Caroline beforehand.
This is point travel goals.
I want to ask a question but I
can't put my hand up first. Yeah,
you're the first person
anyway. Yes. Great.
So you,
um, maintain analogy of a computer and
you said that everything is an app you
download or programs down but don't people
and even children are born with like
some pre made software like children's
share or something without people
teaching them how to share.
You can't have that. It's
a physical. But then again,
this is neurological so we download stuff
but it becomes part of our neurology.
So for example,
if somebody has down syndrome and
there's gene 21 and it's not effective,
it's not working as effectively as
maybe other people. That's part of it.
Their and urology,
that's part of their genetic makeup.
But I don't believe that people
are born with emotional, um,
been pessimists or been depressed. I,
if you look at all of the research,
every bit of research that's out there,
it's all based on behavior and taught.
So what you feel and what you think would
literally affect the chemicals in your
body and your neurology.
If I think negatively,
cortisol and adrenaline
are released in my body.
If I think happy taught or I look at
something positive chemicals such as
norepinephrine and Serotonin,
which has antidepressants, um,
Dorf mean they're all flooded my body
and that has a physical response.
So there are obviously the right,
it's like we're, we're physically,
we all look different because we
have different genetic makeups,
but on an emotional level it's
neurological and that can be changed.
Does that answer your question?
Thank you. Anyone else with them?
One final question. You'd like them.
Great.
Hi.
So we have busy days and have been,
it's always running and I
know it's called the home.
Do you have any tips on kind of like
finding in yourself and pretty makes you
tick and you know to find that purpose
to go after and that's it instead of
getting lost in the day to day stuff,
set a time, set aside time
on one day a week, one hour,
one day a week to take a pen and paper
and literally write down on the top my
why. Why is it that you want to
do you know what you want to do?
It's just to the condition
that's clouding yet.
But you know what you want to do because
when you get up in the morning, um,
you go, I'd love to do this today
or we'd love to do that today.
Or if I said to you, are you creative
person and you go yes or no or whichever.
Or are you someone who loves like an
adrenaline buzz? You'd say yes or no.
You'd know those questions because there
are better questions to ask yourself.
So what kind of a person am I? What do I
enjoy? What makes me go, yes, I really,
really enjoyed that. Or, you know,
are you a people kind of person?
If you're a people person and
you take on a solitary job,
you're never going to be happy in it.
So when you start to write out what is
it that's your wife or play around with
it,
rather than trying to be stiff with it,
just play around with what
it is that you want to do.
Then you put the passion behind it.
You'll only get passionate when
you trade out. Most honestly,
most people here and in the rest of the
world don't know what they want to do
simply because they haven't asked
themselves kids. If you ask the child,
what do you want to be?
I want to be superman or I want to be
a nurse or I want to be a doctor or
whatever.
It's not necessarily that they do,
but in that moment they do so they just
don't question it and adults go, Yay, oh,
isn't that lovely? That's so
cute. So they get a reward for it.
Or if a child does something,
everyone celebrate.
If a child stands up and walks and takes
the first step, everyone celebrates.
So if few start asking yourself
positive questions and then you kind of
celebrate those questions
or reward yourself.
When you do something that you love,
your brain will start to physically
respond to it as a practice for brains.
Some people consider it prior to the
limbic system is called the anterior
singular cortex. And what that does is
that is responsible for award rewards,
impulses and desires, and that part
of the brain, especially in women,
and activate a very,
very easily when you give yourself a
reward and it tags it to the thing that
you're doing. Thank you very
much for the last 30 seconds.
Final question is,
who inspires you?
My mother, she passed away two years ago,
but everything that she taught me, um,
has inspired me. Now I know
people think, you know,
it should be some celebrity or somebody.
That's what everybody knows. But for me,
being the best that you can be and having
good morals and values and having good
integrity, that inspires me. I
don't care who the person is.
And so my mother for sure,
she taught me how to be grateful
for everything that I have not,
and they're like grateful for your dinner
way or those people starving somewhere
else. And you should be grateful in
a way that to genuine only a preset.
If these were gone, would you give
me a billion euro for your hands?
Not a full,
but yet everyone just takes
for granted what they have.
Would you give me a billion
euro for your clothes?
Not a hope.
If you had to take them off and try and
go around everywhere you might get them
to be at home with whatever transaction.
Would you give me your
eyes for a billion euro?
But most of us think we have to be
grateful for everything out there.
Where my mother is,
she inspired me to understand,
I suppose at the beginning
of the desperation,
but to understand that there's
stuff that you actually have,
if you become grateful for it,
you actually become a
stronger person every day.
And it's something that she taught me
from my nose, like the Phif. Um, she said,
say 10 things that you're
grateful for everyday,
10 things and it's very hard to stop.
The team wants to start going.
I'm grateful for my eyes. I'm grateful
for my hands. I'm grateful for my big toe.
If it was gone,
I've Hade.
I'm grateful for the seat that I
sit and I'm grateful that he's here.
I'm grateful for that.
You know,
we're in a safe environment and
get the list goes on and on,
but as soon as you start to do that,
your brain starts to open up and think
differently. So she inspires me most.
That's great. Thank you very much. So
[inaudible].